apple has finally revealed their new m2
macbook air and macbook pro and one of
the biggest questions i'm seeing
floating around online is exactly how
the m2 chip compares to the higher end
m1 pro chip that's available in the 2
000 14 inch macbook pro because some
people actually think that the m2 is
basically as fast but they're wrong
way wrong so what i'm gonna do in this
video is compare everything between the
m2 and m1 pro including all aspects of
the performance as well as the feature
differences to help you decide if you
can save a lot more money by going with
a new m2 macbook now before i jump into
estimating the performance of the m2
chip and comparing it to the f1 i want
to compare the actual m2 and m1 pro dies
and talk about the main differences that
we can see thankfully friedrich orange
on twitter created this graphic analysis
of the dies so let's quickly run through
some of the main differences and what
they'll mean to you first up you can see
that the ram interface on the m2
supports up to 100 gigabytes per second
memory bandwidth and that's because it
connects two chips of lp ddr5 ram
running at 6400 megahertz clock speed
which i honestly didn't expect from
apple because that ram is pretty
expensive now the m1 pro die essentially
gets two of those basically identical
interfaces with identical ram speed
which means that it has a wider
256 bit memory bus allowing for more
memory traffic to flow through it which
means that some apps that really rely on
ram will be faster like photo editing
moving on you can see the m2's gpu only
comes with up to 10 cores instead of 16
on the m1 pro which gives us a little
hint at the performance we should be
expecting and as far as a cpu the m2 has
four performance cores compared to eight
performance cores on the m1 pro and you
might notice that the m2 cores are
actually quite a bit larger so each one
should actually be more powerful but as
far as the efficiency course the m2 has
four of them compared to only two on the
m1 pro so this means that the m2 chip
should be more efficient when running
simple tasks leading to better battery
life then we have the neural engine
which looks to be quite a bit larger on
the m2 chip because it's actually the
second generation neural engine with up
to 15.8 trillion operations per second
directly from the a15 chip compared to
the m1 pro's older version with only 11
trillion now this red section shows five
i o points on the m2 chip with two of
them being used up by the two
thunderbolt controllers behind them
meaning that you should get full
thunderbolt transfer speeds from both of
the ports on the m2 macbooks however the
really weird downside is that the m2
macbooks still only support one external
monitor which is basically an artificial
software limitation because the m2 chip
definitely has enough graphics
performance to support two displays now
on the m1 pro everything gets doubled
because the 14 inch macbook pro comes
with a lot more ports including three
thunderbolt 4 ports and then finally the
last thing i want to point out is the
media engine which has actually been
upgraded on the m2 and perhaps the
number one benefit it has over the m1
pro which i'll get into in just a minute
but now it's time to get into the actual
performance charts and benchmarks to
show you guys how these two compare now
apple did give us numbers for the m2
chips performance boost over the m1 chip
18 faster for the multi-core cpu
performance and 35 faster for the gpu
but as far as the single core
performance we're gonna have to estimate
that ourselves and the best way to do
that is to compare the performance
difference between the a14 ship and the
a15 chip within the iphone because as i
showed you guys in yesterday's video the
m2 chip literally just packs a 15
performance cores compared to the m1
which packs a 14 performance course so
the difference in performance should be
the same for the m2 chip compared to the
m1 according to our iphone comparison
video from last year the a15s single
core performance is 9.3 percent faster
than the a14 so if we bring that
difference over to the m1 and m2
situation we should expect the single
core performance of the m2 chip to sit
at around
1876 points which is about 6.3 percent
faster than the m1 pro so what this
means for you is that the m2 chip should
be faster at common single core tasks
like opening up apps and browsing the
web so it should feel a bit more snappy
compared to the m1 pro now moving on to
multi-core performance i added apple's
18 performance boost claim to the m1 to
give us
8738 points for the m2 but as you can
see the bend 8 core m1 pro is still 13.5
faster than the m2 and the unbind 10
core m1 pro is a massive 44 faster than
the m2 so yes if you need as much
multi-core cpu performance as you can
get for things like xcode programming
photo editing music production or
whatever else the m1 pro is still the
way to go but you obviously have to pay
a lot more to get it now moving on to
the graphics performance i added apple's
35 performance boost claim to the m1 to
give us 28
874 points for the 10 core m2 chip and
then i simply took a fifth away from
that to give us 23 099 points for the
band 8 core m2 model in the macbook air
and now comparing that to the m1 pro
even the bend 14 core model destroys the
full 10 core m2 model being about 20
faster and the full 16 core m1 pro is an
even larger 37.5 percent faster so once
again the m1 pro is much faster in terms
of graphics performance making it more
viable for high performance tasks like
gaming but honestly the m2 chip getting
over 28 000 points in metal is more than
enough for 90 of the people out there
and it's probably gonna be more than
good enough for some light gaming like
league of legends or minecraft or
whatever else and as far as the cpu
performance the m1 chip was already good
enough for the majority of common tasks
and even productivity work as well so
the m2's cpu is definitely enough for
almost everybody and it's actually
pretty nice that apple gave users the
option to upgrade to 24 gigabytes of ram
for those who really need more than 16
gigs without having to pay 2 400 for the
14 inch macbook pro with 32 gigs of ram
but now the last thing i've got to go
through is the one area where the m2
chip will likely be faster than the m1
pro and that's video editing using
common formats like h.264 and hevc
currently when exporting video the m1
pro chip is being drastically limited by
the encoders and we know this because
exporting a 5 minute 4k h.264 video
takes exactly 2 minutes and 55 seconds
no matter which m1 pro model you're
using and it's only 9 seconds faster
than the original m1 chip which is much
slower across the board in terms of both
cpu and gpu performance but now the new
m2 chip has a brand new media engine
that now supports 8k h.264 hevc and
prores encoding and decoding compared to
the m1 pro which only has 8k pro resin
coding but not 8k h.264 and hevc and
that 8k encoding scales down to 4k
linearly which will be 4 times faster
than ak because it has 4 times less
pixels so basically this confirms that
the m2 chip will actually be faster for
editing those common h.264 and hevc
formats but as far as the real world
performance for other tasks we're
definitely going to be comparing it
directly when we get these new m2 max in
next month so if you haven't already
click the circle above to subscribe so
you don't miss out on those videos and
definitely check out our m2 macbook air
buyers guide right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]